aide moi vous avez l'air des
spécialistes de l'ovale et de l'érotisme
en bouteille en bouteille oui
chaque semaine nous parlons d'une revue
vous avons choisi cette semaine la règle
du jeu c'est une revue dirigée par
bernard-henri lévy et guy scarpetta qui
parle de tout qui s'est beaucoup engagée
pour le combat dans l'ex yougoslavie qui
parle aussi bien de poussins dans ce
dernier numéro que de bart et de
michelet que du bilan des années
mitterrand
mais il ya aussi pour la première fois
dans cette revue un premier texte signé
d'un auteur de 26 ans
il a pourtant toutes ses dents il
s'intitule jubilation vers le ciel il se
trouve que c'est vous alors je lis un
extrait de votre premier texte publié la
première fois qu'une fille a vu mon sexe
je devais avoir 6 ou 7 ans nous partîmes
dans un sous-bois c'était un mercredi
après-midi et nous n'avions pas classe
je revois ces mots les piquer par les
orties une noire une lueur opalescentes
de ciel tremper les jets d'eau les
pelouses fraîche et cetera pour décrire
votre enfance que vous avez décidé de
prendre la plume
non je vous auriez dû citer journées de
la fin d'un cycle et qui résume à mon
avis le mieux ce petit article
c'est ce que les femmes préfèrent chez
moi c'est me quitter ses débuts c'est le
début et ça commençait mal j'ai pas
voulu comment ça chauffe vous a commencé
très bien en fin de programme
je trouve que autant il est fascinant de
séduire des sites séduire autant je
pense que la phase de re séduction une
fois qu'on a perdu quelqu'un est encore
plus passionnante
il ya tout l'art de se faire oublier de
deux manières infinitésimale essayer de
revenir de poser quelques jalons
quelques pièges de temps en temps et je
trouve que la réduction est un art
complètement oublié on part toujours de
la séduction que faire pour séduire une
femme si elle vous qui sas a demandé
rien à continuer je m'arrange toujours
pour qu'elle me quittes afin de pouvoir
séduire et d'une certaine façon cela
vous utilisez larmes de l'écriture c'est
plus difficile que ça parce que en fait
je pense que lorsqu'on a un bébé
écrivain un bébé écrivain oui je pense
que en fait
un bébé bouteille et vous êtes un bébé
écrivant oui tout simplement j'ai cette
modestie là parce que je pense que
lorsqu'on commence à écrire qu on est
débutant c'est pas un pinceau dans les
mains qu'on a pour dessiner des camaïeux
comme ça des bayles des belles peintures
sur bois
on a seulement un pistolet à peinture et
de façon baveuse comme ça un peu
anarchique
on essaye de faire des belles courbes et
en fait ça fait d'infâmes tags des on
vise le camaïeu et finalement on fait
des tags sur une espèce de mur et on a
au moins la modestie de enfin j'ai au
moins c'est par ici pas chez vous ça
viande non mais beaucoup ont parlé de
bouche ont parlé de bouche tout se
recoupe je pense je pense que lorsqu'on
commence à écrire comme moi oui c'était
pour vous et on aide la bouche
toutes les couches c'est cette base je
mens je la revendique dans ce sens que
le la règle du jeu pour moi une sorte de
landau ont offert une bavette je suis un
bébé qui peut ses premiers gémissements
jeu comme ça sur ma layette et je crois
que pour pousser ses premiers
vagissements une revue quelque chose de
très important et cette revue la règle
du jeu a cette capacité qu'ont peu de
revues d'être à mon avis d'offrir une
certaine forme d'ouverture c'est à dire
que c'est le cas de le dire oui 20 dire
que c'est ça fait plaisir de savoir
qu'aujourd'hui lorsqu'un jeune comme
c'était encore un peu macho pour un
jeune homme comme vous au lieu de - non
c'est on aime des femmes et voilà
qu'elle se crispe du sable plein les
yeux s ennuie du monde elle réclame des
glaciers des îles à cocotiers des eaux
par la fleur d'oranger elle appelle les
oranges et les étés les aubes amoureux
vous pardonnons frange moussu non jeu
mais si tu es mais là je décris
seulement la femme dans son cercueil une
fois que on a acquis elle nous a offert
cette fidélité posthume puisque une fois
qu'elle a enfin qu une fois qu elle a
enfin accepté de mourir
on est enfin délivré en tant que martyr
de l'odieux génie des femmes de toutes
ces souffrances qu'elle doit faire
endurer pendant des années enfin là on
les voit sous terre quoi qui nous
offrons une délivrance parce que au
moins on sait où elles sont elles sont
pas avec jean-michel avec thierry en
train de faire je ne sais quoi pendant
qu'on regard qu del rey avec cédric
klapisch ou avec jérôme garcin
voilà qui est redoutable il pense on n'a
pas là cette paranoïa qui consiste à
essayer d'apprendre du baudelaire parker
pour les impressionner
pendant qu'elles sont pendant qu'elles
sont en vacances de sports d'hiver avec
jean-michel jean-louis dans des costumes
fluo ridicule et que nous on essaye de
de bavay des quelques rimes pour les
reconquérir toujours la reconquête
ben merci yann moix et puis bonne chance
bonne chance pour cette suite on va y
avoir une suite
et ce n'est qu'un début la première
partie d'un roman à voilà qui très
brièvement qui raconte la poursuite d'un
homme par une femme qui essaie de
conquérir pendant 40 années de
reconquérir pendant 40 années
donc ce n'est qu'un début continuons le
combat merci anne mois donc s'être 20
comment marco del rey c'est l'écart
début continuons nos débats et donc ce
premier texte est publié dans la revue
la règle du jeu
[Musique]